today i'm going to talk about another
gentleman and he's a mathematical
physicist
uh we call him mathemagicians his name
is
nick lucid and the question is how lucid
is mr nick
okay let's find out okay this is his
brief uh biography
i say he's uh curly look alike you know
three stooges
looks pretty much like him he talks like
him if you hear the sound of his voice
that sounds like curly
uh maybe doesn't have that uh new york
new jersey
accent uh but yeah he talks
he's got the same pitch i think anyways
he's got a masters in mathematics
uh he says he got at the university of
crazy his own words by the way okay
you see not ucla just uc okay
university of crazy he's got a youtube
channel
rightly called the science asylum
and i have to believe that that alone
gives me an idea that mr lucid is uh
not a dumb guy out there he's got some
intelligence
he recognizes it's all crazy that's all
he in fact he calls his uh
followers crazies right he realizes
science out there is quite crazy and
and uh i think he has this intuition
that something is wrong out there but
you know he's trying to make some money
he's trying to hit the big time
and you know he's trying to get there to
places to
to people like uh neil tyson and michio
kaku
and uh brian green and all these guys uh
so
you know they try to get up there and so
that's commendable no
nothing wrong with that the problem i've
got with with mr lucid is that
he's using quantum mechanics and general
relativity he's trying to
trying to spread uh these two religions
that's what he's doing and that's where
i have a problem with uh
with mr lucid okay and it turns out that
um like a lot of these uh
internet um physicists
mathematical physicists they go in there
and they branch off into
things which are um which they consider
part of their subject matter and one of
those
we covered a couple of those one was
extinction the other one was whether
there's life out there in the universe
and another one is this one which uh mr
irwin schrodinger uh talked about also
in his latter days he
he talked about uh life uh
schoner went from uh cats that are half
dead and half alive to
where did the chicken come from with
chicken in the egg situation
and so mr lucid goes through the notions
that we have today in bali biology he
says
that's his starting point he says well
you know uh living thing
is something that has organization grows
uh reproduces has a metabolism
uh homeostasis uh response and
adaptation
so he's trying to define what life is
and and that's where he's going with
this and it's
in response essentially to the question
posed by schrodinger you know what is
life
uh does it belong in physics well i say
it does because remember how we divide
science science is divided into physics
and philosophy
philosophy deals with reasons and
purpose
whereas physics deals with causes and
mechanisms and this falls life
what is life and working with life and
doing
explanations in in everything that's
alive except
the mental part the purpose and reason
other than that i think it belongs
squarely within physics so i think it is
within the
subject matter and i do cover just as
much as
anybody else okay so that's his starting
point
um where does he go from there
well he goes to this he goes to the to
analyze each one of those attributes and
so mr lucid says well organization what
is that well made of
one or more cells that's what
organizations essentially means
is it made out of cells okay um does it
grow
says it should be able to grow it
interacts within its environment
absorb absorbing energy whatever energy
is you know they absorb all this
magical stuff the spirit uh it should
maintain itself it should respond to
changes
and uh it should adapt to those changes
okay
but he says that's what life does it's
not what life
is okay so we gotta distinguish what
life
does from what it is okay so what is
life let's see where he goes with this
so he goes in there and he says look
uh and he's trying to show that there
are things that which
we don't consider as life but which have
properties of life and so you have to
kind of find out you know which ones
you're going to select which ones you're
going to reject which ones
are going to qualify as living entities
which ones are not
so he goes through this little list here
and just a very brief one he says like
fire you know fire goes
up right it grows reproduces response to
the environment absorbs
energy so uh is fire alive
how about a virus you know virus also uh
you know it um
it um we have this virus now covet
right a virus uh seems to move you know
it goes inside the body it starts
growing and reproducing it does a lot of
these things right
it adapts to its environment uh and he
was analyzing
uh game of life okay he says look that
one
meets all the conditions of life it's
made of cells it grows it consumes you
can see it up there on the right hand
corner
uh consumes computer energy maintains
themselves responds adapts to digital
environment reproduces
it does everything that life does so is
that a living entity there
would you include it in under the living
so this is this is how he's gonna knock
these things out okay he's going to try
to
eliminate he wants to eliminate the
the criteria that the biologists use
because they say they're not universal
okay so he's whittling one by one right
and uh here's a
another uh he says he gives this
uh explanation he says uh
but these are not biological life those
those
uh uh things that he just mentioned you
know his fire and
the game of life right she said those
are not biological life
so it's not what the checklist was meant
for
the list is only for biologists that
list right
the one he he mentioned there he says no
reason to believe that life on other
planets would share these qualities
worker bees can't reproduce you know
it's the queen who
reproduces right so are the workers not
alive you know
so he's got a right so reproduction is
not necessary criterion for life
yeah and i wrote that in my book i said
you know grandma
i mean your grandma uh when she's 60 70
years old does she reproduce
does that mean she's not alive i mean
you know
so we've got we have many cases many
examples to show that
all those criteria uh cannot be used or
most of them at least cannot be used to
define the word life
so what is life in the alternative
that's we need to get to the bottom of
that right
and one group that tried to define life
is nasa okay and nasa has to define life
because
they're going to go out there to mars or
to some other planet maybe
or they try at least they're thinking
about this and so they're going to have
to try to figure out uh if there's life
over there but before they can find life
they got to define life
what is life so this is their definition
again it's a very biological and i think
it was uh
done by a biologist uh that work at nasa
self-sustaining chemical system capable
of darwinian
evolution okay self-sustaining
darwinian evolution yeah i don't think
it was written by a priest
okay so um
that's their definition that's what
they're looking for when they go to mars
whatever that is
okay and uh
but uh nick also says well yeah but we
got a problem even with that because
look we have uh
this situation where you say um it
doesn't have to be evolving it just has
to be capable of doing so
and so he also mentions you know the uh
calamarine colony of star trek right it
looks
like that smoke that you see up there
okay looks like
like that it says is a swirl of ionized
gas floating in space
okay their life is based on electricity
okay he's thinking of you know some kind
of crystal cells or whatever so it meets
a lot of the conditions of life but
would you consider that a living entity
and he says if we can imagine
life like this and the laws of physics
don't prevent their existence
then we have to at least be prepared for
the possibility
okay we should restrict our definition
of life
at chemistry because to chemistry
because that's what life on earth
looks like okay so we shouldn't just uh
limit
life in the universe which is a good way
of doing it you know universal law
uh universal life should limit it just
to what we see here on earth maybe
there's a broader definition of life
that we should take into consideration
okay and i think that's a good
focus for that right okay okay
so um he ends up
going back to schrodinger he likes
schrodinger's definition he says
life emerges from complexity all we need
for that is metabolism
and homeostasis life should consume
energy to maintain its own existence
through some kind of complex yet ordered
process
ordered ordered uh sounds like an
opinion
sounds like religion uh and urban
he got that from schrodinger who said
life this was his conclusion right after
writing that book he says life is a
constant fight against the increase in
entropy entropy
mathematical concept suddenly entered
biology
okay suddenly uh life has something to
do with
entropy and entropy is what an opinion
okay
what is entropy okay so let's find out
what entropy is
okay and here we have uh
mr um well uh entropy is a measure of
ordinary
disorder that's a short version it's a
little more complex than that but
that gives you an idea they're talking
about order and disorder and
uh what mr lucid says the second law of
thermodynamics
in a closed system entropy tends to
increase over time
the universe is a perfectly closed
system
i don't know about that because uh i
mean i i agree with that but
i don't know if the mathematicians will
agree with you because everybody says
the universe is infinite and so you know
i don't know what he meant by a closed
system if the universe is infinite
meaning uh what that
matter extends forever you know you got
to define that a lot
more closely than what he did here but
let's continue
it started in a state of extremely low
entropy
it started what do you mean it started
well he's referring to the big bang
there you see that big
explosion there that's what he's talking
about he says
matter was created from nothing and of
course nothing is that energy that was
there before
nothing was there so we have uh
we have a little problem with the origin
of the world because they go into
creationism
it's all these religious people who have
occupied the positions of mathematical
physics
and they are the ones calling calling
the shots today okay
so he starts out with a big bang matter
was created and where is it going well
it's on its a seemingly endless march
towards maximum entropy meaning you know
not to the big crunch because that would
be the end of entropy
end of everything no no it's like it's
expanding forever
and he says towards pure randomness a
perfectly
uniform universe so i guess we're going
to be filling the
blocked universe as i said the other day
okay
as part of the universe life cannot
break this law
law law by god i guess but it does
resist okay so we resist
the increase in entropy we're packages
of low entropy low randomness what are
we resisting
we're resisting the increase in entropy
the
increase in this this order
okay so again we're going to concepts
here we're going
you know they're talking about order and
disorder those are opinions what's order
to you
is uh what's this order to you like when
you look at the universe
father universe for him is very well
organized he says hey
i i know where every atom in the
universe is
and here it forms part of a star over
there it forms part of a planet
and over there it forms part of an
asteroid or whatever
so as far as he's concerned everything
is the proper order it's us we see all
that
chaos all that disorder in the universe
okay we see this order it's an opinion
that's what order is
okay um so
yeah we have a different universe we
don't have this uh
big bang universe we say there's a
single thread in all
space that space that thread coils
around turns into
atoms and all these atoms are
interconnected because they're all part
of that same system
and there at the bottom you left you see
the
main proposal which is the expansion and
contraction of the atoms and that's how
they torque the rope which is
what we call light very simple system
very straightforward mother nature is
not
complicated at all she's the simplest
and symmetric woman that you've ever
seen okay
okay so what does nick lucid conclude
with well he says the following he says
just drawing a line between the live
things and not alive things
is a tough challenge especially when you
don't define the word life
and then you run into these kind of
problems it might be impossible
well no you got to be able to define the
word life what do you mean it's
impossible
what's this impossible only for
religious people it's impossible
uh physicism had better be able to
define the word life and i mean by
physicists one of the branches which is
biology
what is the study of what is biology
study what does a biologist study he
studies life
if he doesn't define the word life i
can't call him a biologist
and turns out we have no biologist on
planet earth because not one
has been able to and can define the word
life and that's what he's referring to
maybe it's impossible
yeah so we're doing biology and nobody
defined life which is the study of
biology
great so go for a definition that is
more universal okay i like that no
problem there
life is own and this is his final
definition he i guess he takes
essentially uh schrodinger's definition
modifies it a little bit that's what he
puts there he says life is only a matter
that has
is only matter that has taken control of
its own destiny
okay yeah uh living things actively
prevents
entropy from increasing within itself a
package
of self-maintained order
again what is ordered you is this order
for me so
i don't know what you're talking about
when you say order
order order said hitler yeah order
order said the judge order in the court
um
how do we define life let's define a
forum okay so we have a
scientific definition of life one that
is universal like he said
one that applies to all living entities
okay the universal
here it is living we begin with the word
alive and living
because that's the life is simply a
group of them
and it's a natural object that moves
against the path of least resistance
essentially a living being as has the
ability to move against gravity
okay and yeah you can move also against
water uh
air whatever you know so you can move
against
the pool of gravity or the push of the
water
that's what a living entity is no inert
object can do that so a virus is not
alive because a virus
out here cannot move it's an inert
molecule
that's all it is when it enters the cell
that's when it reproduces and does its
magic because it doesn't
you know through this chemical process
chemical reaction
um it's a chemical physical
a little bit of everything in there but
a virus out here is just a molecule
if i can put a molecule if i can make it
big so you can see it i could put a
molecule on in my hand
it can't do anything it just stays there
it's like a rock
it's a molecule that's all it is it's
like getting a
grain of salt and putting it in your
hand does that move no it doesn't
and this is no virus is no different
and fire fire goes up the walls but it's
not
a natural object first of all fire is
not an object it's a
process of combustion so you can't use
fire
so you can't use fire because fire is
not a thing
and it takes two years to train people
what a thing is they think it's an easy
question but it's not
a thing is that which has shape it's not
that which you can touch or see
and for sure a thing is not a process
like fire is
okay so fire is not an object you can't
use fire as an object or flame for that
matter either
when i discussed that a couple weeks ago
but
uh it's got to be a natural object not
an artificial one i mean we have air toy
airplanes they fly
uh we we have real airplanes they fly
right
and uh balloons they fly against gravity
yeah but see it's got to be a natural
object now if you want to include
artificial things such as the game of
life
well you can do that if you just remove
the word natural from there just say an
object that moves against gravity fine
if you can do that with with the game of
life right uh
pixels or whatever
[Music]
the issue is what are you going to use
that definition for
i mean does it have any meaning to say
to include pixels
under life is that what we think of is
life
now you have to have a universal
definition
that mother nature created you know and
that's got to be only
motion against gravity or against the
path of least resistance that's all it
is
and uh so that's it in a nutshell that's
uh the definition of life and all these
people who
are like nick lucid who do
quantum mechanics and relativity they
actually do a disservice to science
i mean i i don't blame them for trying
to make a buck on youtube
you know i think it's uh i mean you have
all these girls that
they show their boobs out there and they
also make a lot of money and uh so
and he they get more hits than he do
[Laughter]
but uh i think he does a disservice when
he um
he uh essentially regurgitates
relativity and quantum and spreads it as
truth to people who just come to see him
for entertainment
see the the people in harvard and
cambridge they don't they don't have
too much respect for people like uh
like nick lucid because they want to do
real science out there what they call
real science
and so when a person like him goes out
there and does his little show
and he's doing more entertainment and
people that
sign up to his uh channel do it right
primarily for entertainment
it's like going to see the circus the
the clown at the circus
and the problem is that you feed people
the wrong stuff the irrational stuff you
feed them
uh the quantum atom you feed them the
quantum
version of light you feed them the
quantum version of electricity
and magnetism so on and that's where the
crime
comes in and yeah he's trying to make a
buck he's trying to get up there in the
world that part i don't
i don't criticize him for but the fact
that he's spreading
this nonsense i have a problem with okay
so much for nick lucid i don't think
he's
very lucid when it comes to quantum
mechanics and general relativity my only
hope is that he does
think that it's that he's in a science
asylum and he's trying to get out of
there
or make some money out of it